[Music]
hello and welcome to Sophie Cohen
visionaries I'm Sophie Shephard nonsense
self-driving cars are already on our
roads but how will it change the way we
live well I had a chance to talk about
this with a legend of American auto
industry former vice chairman of General
Motors Robert Lutz Bob Lutz it's really
great to have you with us welcome to
Moscow thank you all right so you are
saying that in 15 20 years human driven
vehicles will be replaced by unmanned
vehicles what makes you think it will
happen so soon I mean in parts of the
world we see how people they're like
driving horses and carriages I mean that
kind of proves that integral methods
don't go away so quickly it's true and I
may be a little optimistic with my 15 or
20 years it could be you know 15 to 30
but it is going to happen faster than
most people think because the technology
is available for instance in the United
States we're seeing the first fleets of
unmanned robotic taxis hitting the
streets of San Francisco in 2019 and I
think once it starts in the large cities
it will it will make very rapid progress
because people will find that it's a
much more efficient and safer form of
Transportation so I'm skeptical about
all that so let's go point by point
because I'm an old-fashioned kind of
girl first of all you saying that
eventually human during cars will be
banned from highways as potentially
dangerous so does that mean that once
there will be only autonomous model is
on the road there will be no more
accidents well I think you of the
general consensus is that accidents will
be reduced by 93 to 96 percent so will
there be the occasional malfunction or
will we have a situation where the
autonomous vehicle is placed in front of
a in a moral dilemma for instance
suddenly the autonomous vehicle sees a
child in its path but it can't stop
because it's going too fast and the
other alternative is to go off to the
side and hit a tree so does it run over
the child and keep the drivers safe or
does it keep the child safe and go off
and run into a tree and there will be
cases of calling moral dilemmas where
the vehicle whichever choice the vehicle
makes is going to be the wrong choice
well I mean that's the that's the whole
point the biggest point I thing is also
selling the trust first of all
psychologically when you're in an
autonomous car how do you trust Sir
Robert I mean we see like you've just
given me an example of that how there
would be problems with the dilemma which
Dracula child or do I hit a tree and
kill the driver or like we already know
that an autonomous car has killed a
cyclist I mean he only takes a few
accidents like that and then you know in
the news and then people won't be able
to believe the company that day were the
Volvo in the United States hit the woman
with the bicycle first of all all of the
autonomous vehicle features of the car
had been disabled and basically the
driver was in control so that's not that
the press like that but on that same day
in the United States 130 pedestrians or
cyclists were killed by normal cars
driven by humans nobody talks about that
so nobody is nobody is trying to say
that there will be zero accidents but it
will be less than 1/10 of what we have
today but how do you sell the trust to
people psychologically because it will
sit because when you are in charge is
that you were in charge and you can
blame yourself but like we see drones
killing wrong people all the time right
let me let me remind you of the days
when people wouldn't get into an
elevator unless it was a friendly
elevator operator who held the handle
and made sure everybody was in and then
he closed the doors you remember the old
scissors type doors it's crisscross then
he'd closed the inner door
then the outer door would close and then
he'd move the handle and go to the next
floor and now we're in autonomous
elevators and nobody worries about it
and all of the airports have autonomous
trains that take you from terminal to
terminal so it's just it's just a
question of people getting used to it
and then we shouldn't forget that the
first couple of million users especially
in the United States are not going to be
individuals the first couple of million
users are going to be fleets like FedEx
and UPS and the US Postal Service it's
gonna happen to all those truck drivers
are they gonna be out of business you
know what happens in every industrial
revolution is people are displaced from
one area and over time they have to find
jobs in another area but yes I think
anybody who makes their living as a
delivery driver or a garbage truck
driver or a bus driver or a taxi driver
is is in a couple of decades it's going
to have to find something else something
else to do I regret it myself I mean I'm
a passionate driver I used to
participate in automobile races I I like
nothing better than high-performance
cars I I like to think I'm a better
driver than most people so will I miss
it well yes I will and no I won't
because I'll be dead by the time we're
gonna talk a lot about the psychological
aspect and cultural aspect as well
before we get to it I do a lot of stuff
about cybercrime and I know how easy it
is to actually still something online so
considering that this car will be
completely automated and you know wire
to the online industry it's gonna be so
much easier to steal it now I mean you
just have to hack into it and drive away
you don't even have to break the glass
or wire well these vehicles will have to
be very
much hardened from an electronic
standpoint to avoid hacking into them
and disrupting the system and of course
that's the the problem of malware or
malfeasance or people abusing the system
that really exists in anything we do I
mean it's like we do electronic banking
and then you say well we can't have
electronic banking because somebody
could hack into your account and steal
your money well yes they could but and
in some cases it happens but we still
believe in electronic banking and just
because there is some risk of electronic
interference doesn't mean that we we
shouldn't enjoy the benefits of the
technology so also I'm thinking how do
you sell that to Americans because
Americans are fiercely independent
they hate any kind of government
intrusion or control over them this is a
car that could be stopped automatically
for and you know you're stopped for tax
evasion or a car that ultimately drives
you decide where to go I mean how do you
how does that sit with the concept of
Americans being free and super
individualistic well that is that is a
problem and you do give up certain
freedoms you give up the freedom of
being able to vote to violate the speed
limit and you but traffic is so
regulated today that you you know which
lanes you're supposed to be in you you
know where you're supposed to go you
have to stop at stop signs you have to
not go over a certain speed so I mean
human traffic human driven traffic is
very tightly regulated today and you'd
say well probably when they put the
speed limits in fifty or eighty years
ago people said this is outrageous
I don't want to be told I can only do 80
kilometers an hour I want to be able to
do 130 kilometers an hour but people get
used to these things and
at some point it's not going to be it's
not going to be a matter of choice but
because at some point when say a city
government or a state government or even
the national government figures out that
the remaining 30 percent of human driven
vehicles are causing 95 percent of the
accidents what the government does is
says okay that's it you have five years
to dispose of your car and start using
autonomous vehicles like everybody else
but at the end of five years we were
gonna take your vehicle off the road and
that's you know it's it's not popular
but unlike if you try to take guns away
from Americans you're gonna have a
revolution because that violates the
Second Amendment of the Constitution we
have much less deaths please if you try
to take guns away you're gonna have a
revolution but if but for the ability to
drive a car there's no constitutional
amendment that says you have a god-given
right to drive your own car and you're
not really taking anything away because
the actual mobility will be improved the
ability to go from point to point
quickly will be improved and the the
time that you have available for your
personal use will increase because when
you leave work to go home you get into
the autonomous module and you can do
anything you want you know you can pull
the curtains and go to sleep
or you could have the your first drink
of the evening not worry about being
pulled over and free and the thing is
that you see that's that's an excellent
point
when we think about how unreliable human
beings are we would not get into a taxi
or a bus because human beings go to
sleep they drink they have moments of
inattention
we we text on the phone while driving
and so forth and these are all practices
that lead to a lot of accidents we still
don't know how reliable robots are
either because that's still a big
question I mean maybe statistically
you're saying in the future we're going
to have a ratio where robots make less
mistakes and humans but we still don't
have that race oh yes we do oh yeah the
latest technology of autonomous vehicles
as developed by way mo which is a
division of Google or General Motors
with using cruise automation which is a
West Coast startup to the general
motorsport the vehicles have on all the
autonomous task fleets in the United
States they have to report the number of
resets per month and a reset means that
there was a failure and you had to reset
the car General Motors and whammo are
down to like zero resets per month these
things just work and work and work and
work and never have a problem we're
gonna take a short break right now when
we're back we'll continue talking about
how our lives will change with
self-driving cars on our roads taken
over the manual cars talking to xeo
General Motors Robert let's stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with XE of General Motors
Robert Lutz Bob do you feel like
Americans will eventually completely
forget how to drive I think we in
another 30 or 40 years we will have a
situation where little grandchildren or
little children ask their
great-grandparents is it true that all
these cars used to have people driving
them and great granddad said yeah that's
what we used to do and then the kid says
but is it true that you'd have two lane
roads where one car would go this way at
a hundred kilometers an hour and another
car would go this way in a hundred
kilometers an hour and the grand
great-grandfather would say yes that's
what we did and the kids would say well
didn't you didn't you sometimes hit each
other oh yeah it sometimes happens and
the kids will shake their heads and say
yeah I don't know how you people did
that but why not leave the option to the
humans
of actually also be able to drive if
they want it for instance in aviation
the automation of flying is also
happening but in a very different way
with automated car either drives you or
sits total control to you at this point
I don't know what's going to be in like
15 years with planes it's like augmented
piloting route it lets you drive but
doesn't let you do anything stupid why
not go down that road when it comes to
army because you won't get the
efficiency the efficiency and
decongestant the cities and improving
the throughput on the flow of
Transportation on any given Road the
minute you start blending human driven
cars in with the robotic cars you lose
the efficiency because then all the
robotic cars are slowed down by the poor
human reactions
and the poor driving habits of the human
being compared to a compared to a
robotic car I'll give you an example if
you stand at a traffic light and you're
number six or number seven down and the
traffic light goes from red to green you
can count to three before the first
person oh yeah and starts to move then
it's another one to three before the
second person goes so after ten cars
you've got thirty seconds which is most
of the light so if you're number ten in
a line of cars waiting for the light to
change probably you're not going to get
through it because everybody has wasted
three seconds waking up whereas with a
line of autonomous cars when that signal
changes because these autonomous cars
are all connected electronically when
the light changes were actually won't
need a light which it could be an
invisible signal all ten or all fifteen
cars will move at once and they'll move
smoothly and with minimum minimum
front-to-rear separation so a blending
human driven with autonomous is going to
be a necessary thing in a transitional
phase but it's it's not efficient and
but you say well I want to drive I want
to and it's going to be just like the
horse today horses are no longer seen on
the city streets of Moscow or anywhere
else because they're not an efficient
form of transportation they slow
everything down and and frankly they're
you know they're hazardous in and around
automobiles but you can still if you if
you're a horse fan you could still enjoy
your horse you can enjoy it in the
western United States and there are
probably ranches in Russia someplace
where you can go right across the
steppes all you want
and there are horse barns and riding
stables are we gonna have car bars I
mean yes
[Music]
we're starting in the states already do
you have these automotive country clubs
that are springing up around the big
cities where the I would agree the
well-to-do people can keep their cars at
that country club where they have many
cars in the future are gonna be a luxury
for the people that are well-off right
yeah and there will be collectors items
and it'd be like owning a horse today so
what about this psychological concept I
mean we've touched upon it earlier and
he said well I myself love driving
beautiful cars but also I feel like
driving a car is such an integral part
of American culture of becoming an adult
like getting your Driving's license I
mean driving coast to coast route 66 I
mean the whole concept of I'm gonna take
a drive to clear my hand this is a very
American thing cuz we like here in
Russia or in Europe we just go for a
walk yeah I mean how can that go away so
quickly well it is it's actually already
going away in that what we call the
Millennials you know the kids that were
born after after 2000 are the ones who
live in social media well that's right
I mean they're much more interested in
their phones and in contact content and
in video phoning each other and so forth
that is what's consuming their lives now
as electronic technology in the form of
handheld devices and you say and many of
them are not that eager to learn to
drive because they've been driven around
by mom all the time
and that and that's another new freedom
that people don't think about so much is
the freedom to not have to drive your
kids around there all the time anymore
and that you'll be able to send your
small children to certain pre-programmed
known addresses you know like well-known
houses of friends or kindergarten or
whatever to where the kids can take an
autonomous vehicle to go to these
priests priests
specified places old people who can no
longer drive or who are partly blind or
something like that will be able to
safely navigate so in in one sense it
takes away the freedom of holding a
steering wheel but it also replaces that
with the freedom of being able to go
anywhere anytime whether you're healthy
or not whether you can see or not
whether you're asleep or not it whether
you want to work on the wave it doesn't
matter you just get into that module and
it safely takes you where you want to go
and that's that's a form of freedom the
whole concept of turning this
self-driving cars into models is that
they won't be owned right it's gonna be
like sort of like your personal train
compartment it's not gonna be they're
all gonna look at the same they're gonna
all drive at the same speed and then the
American car industry is also based on
individual expression I mean all these
cars that we see advertised on TV
they're ultimately saying that if you
drive me you're better than what we call
I have it and you don't why not like let
the self-driving cars also be different
from each other or looks-wise or will or
compartmentalize why take away that
individuality but but what's the utility
if if all of these modules belong to
fleets and none of them belong to
individuals what's the value in having
them badged Bentley or BMW or Mercedes
the public doesn't care because the
public isn't going to own these things
these things will be owned by the large
transfer all those horseshoes and BMWs
that's gonna go out of business
ultimately yes it's doomed yeah or maybe
they will focus on you know luxury
interior afford this modules instead of
the engine but but see people aren't
gonna own these things so if they don't
own them why bother
and some yes yeah outside this inside
the cities there will be no private
ownership of vehicles the
because the cities do not want these
things cluttering up the city the
average automobile spends 10 less than
10% of its time actually going someplace
the rest of its time it's sitting around
waiting for people to use it and that's
the beauty of autonomous modules they'll
be in use all the time so but out in the
country you know in the suburbs yes it's
quite possible that people will still be
able to own a car and they might be a
van type and they might have all their
vacation AIDS stuff in it you know
tennis rackets and water skis and
everything so that they can always
basement but the problem is once that
once they decide to use it it's going to
have to be entered into the computer
controlled transportation flow they dad
cannot sit behind the wheel and decide
with what they're gonna have to do is
they're gonna have to program in their
destination and then apply to enter into
the traffic flow and it'll only take a
couple of minutes and then they'll be
entered into the traffic flow now one of
the reasons why the city to city modules
have to pretty much all be the same is
because you're going to have on the big
motorways or freeway it says column some
places in the States you will probably
have inductive electric cables which
charge the batteries of the modules
while they're on the freeway and so
these will be these cables will be
embedded in the concrete maybe five six
centimeters below the surface and on top
the modules will have minimal separation
between each other and oh maybe 25 30
centimeters max and they have to be like
sauce
Wheelz because when they're all together
in a train they have to look like a big
long snake and if if you take a train
and you do this with with it with the
railroad cars you have a lot of air
resistance which is why railroad cars
are all long tubes and then they stop
and then there's another long tube
because that's minimal air resistance so
all all the modules will join into this
train and the train will probably go at
like 300 kilometers an hour and when you
get close to your exit your module will
automatically separate out of the Train
and that will go into deceleration lanes
the gap that your module left will be
filled so that in a few seconds you know
it'll all be closed up again then your
module goes under a reader where you
will be charged for the number of
kilometers that you spent on the on the
motorway and then you proceed to your
ultimate destination but and so for
urban use with arrow aerodynamics
play no role in urban use like 60
kilometers an hour or less a resistance
isn't that big a thing but on the
freeway and it will be important for all
of these modules to be basically shaped
like like a big cylinder the time this
evolution is complete you'll probably be
at the point where you'll be glad to sit
back in a module and go someplace
without having to do anything well let's
see what happens thanks a lot for this
fascinating interview was your best of
luck I don't like it either but it's
going to happen because it has to all
right let's we'll just have to go along
with it
Thanks
yes you're quite welcome
[Music]